air is very dry this morning it's
beautiful out there that sun is just
about to crack the horizon off the east
and you can see just a little bit of
that sunlight over the western mountains
the spring mountains the beautiful snow
up there wow it's pretty this morning
and it's pretty cold so kiddos grab a
nice warm jacket parents make sure the
kids have on those warm coats this
morning 37 good average temperature here
over the next hour or so as kids are
getting ready to head out the door for
school 58 this afternoon nice sunshine
not looking for the wind today but it is
coming back pretty quickly and before
the weekend so your wednesday will
finish like this we're looking for a
high of 58. yesterday we were just at 60
which is the average high
for this time in january sunrise
officially at 6 46 takes a couple of
minutes more because of the mountains
sunset at 501 boy if you were around in
1975 do you remember it being almost 80
degrees for today's date that's a little
too warm for january all right so the
snow is kind of winding down across the
intermountain west denver had it
yesterday look how cold though just
barely above 10 degrees 20s for salt
lake
we've got 48 in la and phoenix in the
40s as well things are pretty dry across
the west rain across florida right now
in the far southeast and super cold
still in the upper midwest minus 15
degrees right now in minneapolis chicago
below zero and look at those single
digits for kansas city cincinnati it's
been a little snow over the panhandles
of oklahoma and texas this morning high
pressure rebuilds strengthens and that's
what's going to tighten the pressure
gradient that cold front from yesterday
that brought the winds way south of us
now so it just opened the door for the
cooler air for a little bit lake wind
advisories reissued for lake mead lake
mohave and all along the colorado river
valley again tomorrow where we expect
those stronger north winds now it may
take late in the day or tomorrow night
before we feel those stronger winds for
the valley but they'll be coming back
63 for the high tomorrow so kind of a
roller coaster of temperatures clouds on
saturday and a nice finish to january in
the mid 60s next week but boy we cool
down again right away for february even
mid 50s on wednesday